this year's being jam-packed for the
anime scene and it's certainly not
lacking in terms of grand anime
entrances either in this list we'll
showcase some of our favorite entrances
from this year that left a lasting first
impression whether they introduced a new
character or surprised everyone with a
return or just entered the battle with
style so get ready because we're about
to take a brief look at this year's top
10 anime entrances that'll give you
Goosebumps looking to get a girl's
number well all you have to do is make
an entrance like arira did when he
rescued shizuka from that ridiculous yet
funny scene in Z
100 a zombie shark roaming around hungry
for flesh and Akira dressed as a wannabe
scuba diver himself he decides it's time
to find out what it truly means to be a
hero you might feel like you've stepped
into an episode of my hero Academia but
Akira proves you can can be a hero
without a quirk Akira and shizuka then
quickly assemble some batteries and his
reliable steel suit delivers a punch
with 1 point21 GW the animation was
insane but what's the best moment well
with shizuka being the Mis risk analyst
that she is she's willing to take a
different kind of risk with arira to put
an end to the zombie shark and finally
give her number now that's the kind of
power a fire entrance can give
youbody
next up is a series that was released
not too long ago and Shadow's menacing
and Godlike entrance in the first
episode of the second season of eminence
in Shadow undoubtedly deserves its spot
on our
[Music]
list this scene is a perfect reminder of
what made Sid such a fun protagonist in
the first season while the Shadow Garden
organization he built May understand
real threats like the cult of Dio bolos
Sid views everything in his world as an
opportunity to live out his childish
power fantasies what makes this Scene
Epic or should I say even funnier is
when Sid steals Mary's bars and spits
them all over the city mimicking Mary's
lines like a brainless robot it
definitely solidifies Eminence in Shadow
as one of the funniest isekai anime
series out there the studio behind this
anime clearly knows what they're doing
and you can tell that a lot of thought
and planning goes into every aspect of
it alucard's return in castl Vania
nocturn is next on the
[Music]
list now just when all hope seems lost
our guy alukard makes his epic comeback
and he did it in his swaave style
alukard made a memorable entrance the
moment he impaled drta with his sword
revealing his beautiful and radiant self
saving RoR from his death the moment
alukah faced the minions and introduced
himself as the son of Dracula was cold
making it clear that he would slay them
without Mercy just like thousands of
vampires before them it wasn't a threat
but a statement of blunt simple fact in
that scene he was the moment of course
alukard quickly recognized RoR as a
Belmont descendant thanks to his
trademark whip time will tell if these
two will become as close as alukard did
with the late Trevor with Castlevania
nocturn set centuries after the original
Castlevania series seeing alad's Grand
return in a time of danger has me
excited about what the next series has
in store and on the brink of utter
defeat I hope I'm not too late while
Gundam might not be a regular on our
videos when it does feature it never
fails to leave us in awe so next on our
list is when Gundam caliban arrives
[Music]
K caliban arriving is often compared to
the iconic fa unicorn showcasing how the
witch from Mercury is the culmination of
generations of Gundam it's like a love
letter to the entire franchise nearly
every aspect of the wi from Mercury has
roots in past stories seeing sueta
recover miorin and lead a Counterattack
against quiet zero with the Gundam
caliban a mobile suit lost 21 years ago
in the vanadis incident is back for an
encore and it's epic however as it lacks
protection against the data storm she'll
likely be unavail in the process we
always knew seleta would be compelled to
join the fight sooner or later the fact
that she's willing to sacrifice herself
to save everyone else isn't surprising
considering what we've seen from her
character is a perfect combination of
drama and buildup this makes her
entrance all the more amazing with its
profound
implications
[Music]
[Applause]
this next one is like going from zero to
100 in the blink of an eye ragna awakens
his ultimate power in ragna
[Music]
Crimson ragna once a weak Dragon Hunter
suddenly turns into a total badass kind
of like kilua taking out enemy with the
flick of his hand his entrance into the
awesome fight is anything but ordinary
because ragna's backstory is a painful
one he lost his parents and Guardians to
dragons when he was just a kid and he
blamed himself because for some reason
he's like a dragon magnet then Along
Came leonica showing him kindness and
earning his undying gratitude but things
take a wild turn when a gang of dragons
led by Grim weld attacks their Town his
future self appears and Spills the beans
about the dark events that await ragna
after Leona's death angry at his fate
ragna demands his future self hand over
his power so he can save leonica and
prevent The Bleak future from happening
in the first place even though this is a
new anime the scenes were just
breathtaking the studio did an amazing
job of showcasing Ragnar's potential and
how he's just so overpowered the way his
present and future selves teamed up led
to a powerful entrance in the
[Music]
series entering our top five we have
when freen arrived in front of Aura the
guillotine if you think freen can't get
any more badass then you might have made
the biggest mistake in your life because
she's even colder than your average shm
protagonist this entire scene serves as
proof of just how deadly and Powerful
fre Ren truly is I love how stoic fre
Ren's eyes become when she gets serious
the final moments of the scene show our
protagonist suspended in midair with the
moon at her back casting a chilling
shadow that seems to whisper to the
viewer predicting that the next time
they see her she won't be the character
we've come to know but instead she'll
appear as an angel of death on the
battlefield the transition from the
Moonlight behind Fern to the
overwhelming light behind freerun was a
neat Easter egg by the animators it
provides perspective on just how strong
she's become along with her Apprentice
this beautiful entrance delivers a
stunning cinematic moment highlighting
the beautiful visual presentation that
runs throughout the entire series making
its place on our list get ready because
soon you'll see why demons call her
Freer Ren the
Slayer let's show some L to the amazing
scene when love mitsuri enters to save
everyone in the village in the Demon
Slayer swordsmith Village
Ark
[Music]
she's a total sweetheart when it comes
to rescuing people but when it's time to
fight demons they're in for a real fight
she even offers an apology for arriving
late and ends many of the fish demons
that had infested The Village all the
swordsmiths in the village for head over
heels for the beautiful harida
expressing their gratitude for her
heroic actions with eupo table being a
go to animation skills they didn't hold
back in in this scene the way they
animated her sword is fire it moves like
a slender piece of metal not just a
ribbon and it beautifully highlights her
incredible attack speed amongst the
hashira I also noticed that mitsuri
seems to instinctively know how to
defeat the demon when she arrives to
save the chief what's cool is how she
figures out the Demon's weaknesses she
smashes the vase and Bam it's done that
shows her strength and genius in every
move besides her beauty the animation
and visuals are just mindblowing
stealing everyone's hearts and I got to
admit that includes M
too next on our list we've got some
serious badassy on display with edsu as
he not only makes his entrance but
completely destroys U's Elite guard I am
one
[Music]
Creator and when I say destroys I mean
it as an understatement they got their
butts handed to them with his imperfect
wobbly blade but remember this guy is
the god of swords and he lives up to the
title he's the genius behind the
creation of asoi the base template that
eventually evolves into a shinigami's
unique zanako he proudly proclaims
himself as the number one zanako Creator
and his swordsmanship skills are just as
amazing and that badass walkie pulls off
with the rest of the squad members just
sitting in the background it's pure fire
his strut after taking down Le Barrow
might just be my favorite scene in the
whole anime the books the fights the
dialogue everything about this entrance
screams 10 out of 10 for
[Music]
me moving on to our list of memorable
entrances this one will make you shout
Daddy's
home toi fushi guro's dramatic entrance
in front of his is a moment to remember
toi has long been a fan favorite and
people were eagerly hoping to see more
of him in the ark but his return came
sooner than expected megumi's plans
might have failed but they created an
opening in daron's domain suddenly
someone enters the domain and to
everyone's surprise it's toi fushiguro
who notices the opening from outside and
simply strolls right into dagon's domain
con say it's the best father and son
reunion moment the whole thing was
basically a Power Trip toi took charge
of the battle against dgon and utilized
the play for clown to dominate the fight
ultimately defeating dgon who stood no
chance against toi's unique power yet he
might have interrupted his son's
original plan with the domain but at
least his cool epic entrance sent social
media into a
frenzy I know we feature one piece a lot
in our videos but we just can't help it
and for good reason because this time we
have the moment when Zoro and Sanji
attack king and queen
it just knows how to create explosive
entrances that keep us hooked it's not
just about the battles it's about a
shown in series that's been going strong
for decades even surpassing the classics
in many ways thanks to his animation and
adaptation style when Zoro breaks free
from his bandages and Sanji casually
brushes off the attack he took you know
you're in for something epic the two of
them then deliver their fiercest attack
simultaneously striking both both king
and queen One Piece consistently
delivers moments that earn top spots on
our list and this Shining Moment of Zoro
and sanji's entrance is both cool and
flashy it's an unforgettable entrance
that any Avid fan will
[Music]
love and that's a wrap for our list I
hope you had a blast revisiting some of
the incredible entrances that happened
this year if you have suggestions for
entries you wish we'd covered head on
down to the comments section and let us
know what you think about that don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you never miss another video like
this one till next time